端午節所有的妖孽都要現行
會不會變盤
天年修行
這個玉端午打回原形
多年持股逃不過端午變盤
漲很多
然後持股狀況這個阻力又賣了
這我就要特別注意
它如果去年有端午變盤
今年也要特別留意
12年來的統計資料
有沒有 秀一下有沒有
你看連我的臉都遮住了
變盤啊
扔掉
小哥的必凶三爱草
新鲜货
太棒了
里面90%我都不敢买
期货有个很好的功能
叫做必贤
让你小赚小赔
又不会花很多钱
2%就5000块入袋了
那个木华哥跟小哥
因为我知道两位在
两位我们三个人之前
多少内心都有一点点
空方的思想
可是现在好像完全不能
跟这个市场围
你也把它捏死
对
就一直喷 一直喷 一直喷
只要是空头就斩
对 那怎么看呢
要一直多下去吗
也不可能一直多下去
但是看起来这个市
还是要上
所以我们今天要来告诉大家
因为快要端午节了
坊间有个流传
端午节所有的妖孽都要现行
所以大家会害怕变盘
所以今天要来教大家
如果端午節真的有什麼風吹草動
我們該怎麼做
好喔 絕招拿出來了
絕招拿出來 好
所以今天的理財達人秀
歌有仇必報要來教你什麼呢
我們請到了我們的軟哥木華哥
還有我們的小哥籌碼專家
要來告訴大家
大家應該會很擔心
最近說真的
如果你有一頂點空方的念頭
都得把它捏洗
因為大盤它個股就是一直上一直上
可是你內心是不是跟趙華一樣
充滿了有點恐懼
很害怕說
接下來如果端午節
有沒有所謂的端午變盤
那如果今天真的
一旦市場有風吹草動
你手上報的個股又要除全息了
你又不想賣
請問現在該怎麼做
今天兩位大師要把他們的絕招
全都秀給你
非常簡單讓你報股不會害怕
首先我們要來問我們的總經達人
對 大盤專家沐華哥
到底有沒有端午變盤
這種事情
變盤要看什麼樣的狀況
不過我們其實
就是從過去的統計資料
你看我們多用功準備了
你看 過去這麼多年來
12年
12年來的統計資料
有沒有 秀一下有沒有
你看連我的臉都遮住了
這麼大的 那麼多的數據
莫華哥可不可以一句話蓋光一下
一句話就下面嘛
變盤機率就50%
這個就廢話啦
對不對 怎麼就跌啊
50%就是沒有變盤啊
扔掉
沒關係 直接扔掉
過去不重要啦
12年我覺得很厲害
而且講實在的
你說看前一天 前五天
然後後一天後五天
那其實看不出什麼端倪
看不出端倪
尤其是我們剛剛看到那個12年
它其實漲跌幅度都很小
大概都是零點幾%而已
所以我們去計較那個零點幾%
沒有什麼太大的意義
我們要賺就賺波段對不對
不是 我們要知道就是今年
過去12年法海營一半
白娘子營一半已經不重要了
今年誰會贏
我们就看过去两年就好
我们不要看12年
而且重点在要买对股票
对
而且你要买对标的
对不对
或者说你要买对
什么样的一个概念
很重要
不然大家跟我们信心
现在股民很害怕
哪一次上你节目
落脑了呢
有没有
没有
出去12年从来没有
对啊
每次上你节目
我相信观众朋友
应该都有收获了
这个也不是我笑的
赚钱几率100%
这个是事实嘛
对不对
那我们来看一下
去年的状况
我们来看一下
端午节前后的行情
你就很清楚了
端午节前是不是跌
对
去年我十字游标线
那个正好就是
这个端午节
那个之后的一个交易日
好 所以等于是端午节后
反而是蛇形向上
对啊 蛇形向上啊
节前跌 节后涨啊
那问题是
这个是一个短波段行情
那我们就要放大格局
放大眼光
好
拿出来看 吓死你
有没有
我们圈起来就是
刚刚的那个短波段行情
有没有 就在这一段
刚才那个板就是这一段
节前跌 节后涨这一段
可是后面是大涨
所以它有点变盘
其实是向上变
向上变 没错
所以去年端午节
是一个非常好买点
对 非常好买点
现在追悔有点来不及了
对啊 那2018年
我们来看一下好不好
好 2018年各位可以看一下
节前涨 节后跌
但是它毕竟也是一个
小波段的盘整行情
是 对不对
然后你可以看到后面的
咚咚咚几个坡之后
这个是2018年的行情
跟去年又完全不一样了
那重点在这边
那到底要买什么股票
从2018年可以怎样
从股建金就对了
护国神山
各位看到这个是2018年台积电
端午节后的一个交易日的表现
各位看到十字游标线
就是端午节后的一个交易日
台积电就蹦蹦蹦往上涨
涨到268块
所以大盘看起来是这样这样这样
可是台积电却是一个好的买点
那大家会问说
那今年台积电会不会是一个好买点
端午节
是啊
18年能够今年参考吗
来大家看一下
2019年台积电十字游标线
再秀出来有没有更好买点
大波段346
有没有做到
我懂你意思了
你懂了嘛
我们可能端午要不要变盘
一点都不重要
但是过完端午
通常台积电很有表现
没错
那台积电如果很有表现的话
大盘其实插不到哪里去
可是我们节目是不会单推个股的
那当然我们不是在爆名牌
因为大家都知道台积电
台积电没什么好爆的
重点是台积电是什么概念
什么概念
ESG的龙头概念
永续经营的龙头概念
没错
所以今天的熊黄酒是不是
还是爱草
还是爱草都可以
就是告诉大家这个概念好不好
好 所以等一下你会把这个熊黄草拿出来
告訴我們端午節別的不要管
台積電的概念
ESG的概念
我們等一下來揭露
這一定要好好來把它想清楚
但是因為端午節
我們講到白娘子
就有一點點腰氣對不對
所以腰氣就要靠小哥了
小哥最喜歡收腰了
對 小哥的口袋裡面
那種腰禍很多
我們要講一下
會不會變盤
千年修行
這個玉端午打回原形
多年持股逃不過端午變盤
这很空
你不可以这样
有些股票会有这种疑虑
千年修行打回原形
我报了一千天
不要一千年
一千年前没有股市
三四个月就很长了
我报了一千天
欲端午打回原形
你要小心
因为有些筹码
看起来有点怪怪的股票
局来说我们来看一下
像这一档
最近真的不能有空的念头
要尊敬市场
好
这个我们来看像这档
白蛇谷将现原形
像这档6582的升峰
各位可以看一下
它有主力卖 散户买
然后散户持股比例又很高
大户又在卖
好 所以这档强势股
最近的状况不太对劲
没错 像这种
这个涨很多
然后持股状况
这个主力又卖了
这种就要特别注意
会不会涨一涨之后
端午之后变盘
小哥在暗示最近很强势的
可是筹码上已经开始怪怪的
对 筹码有主力流到散户身上
可是现在散户很厉害
我们之前常讲
散户买的也会涨
散户看完理财单
就每个都变达人
现在很多股票连大盘
也是被散户买上去
不过这个股票
散户买很多还是要小心
像这个毛宝也是主力卖
散户买
对
散布持股比例一直上升
那大欧也下降
股票也在高档
像这种有点清洁用品
它的类防疫概念股
它的营收成长了30%
好像很厉害
营收成长30%
但是它的股价涨了多少
涨了两倍多
像这种就要小心
完全超乎基本面在涨
还没跟上
而且现在筹码有松动
对 有松动
長很多的你要小心
像這個例如說像這個大疆
我們來看一下
大疆在去年的時候
去年它長滿多
長到這個500多塊
端午之後就變盤了一路跌 跌到了100多所以你的意思是大江他如果去年有端午变盤今年也要特别留意
今年就不一定会变盤
因为他也是端午前前有涨的
对 他去年端午前前涨很多
最近跌下来
端午之后跌下来
好 这是他去年的情况
对 那有的人想说
那我大江我就想领他现金鼓励
刚刚有讲嘛 开头有讲
因为最近在除泉席
就算知道端午变盘
我也舍不得放到他的席
而且他有基本面子
做支撑的时候
我会想一直抱下去
那大江鼓励政策不错
他现金鼓励2.688块
在2017年
股票鼓励1.493
愿意配股票鼓励的小哥特喜欢
他有成长的愿景
没错 2018年6.9
现金鼓励 股票鼓励1.49
今年呢
这现金股率8.88
股票股率0元
不听话
不过8.88我还是被吸引了
还是蛮漂亮的
可是呢
你假如发现主力卖超
又想长期之有该怎么办
没错
因为你知道
自从你跟股虞合体之后
对 加上还有慕华哥
有时候有些好股票
我们真的要报比较久
可是报比较久
你就会发现
我赚了股息赔了价差
心情又是不舒服
对
怎么办
怎么办呢
好 我这边呢
就小哥的臂凶三艾潮
好 那我懂了
沐滑哥是熊皇九
你是艾潮
我是艾潮
来看第一个
第一个我们可以
持有限股放空大台好吗
不是限股你要看什么股
如果你刚刚讲的是生计股
像大疆你跟大台
大台哪是大疆在管的
大台是谁在管的
台基电在管的
对 是刚刚沐滑哥讲的在管的
没错
对了你持有限股放空大台
可能会有点问题
对 关联性太低了
对 可能会两边赚或两边赔
你放空大台是整个指数你都不看好
所以你这样子不大好
那第二个呢
持有限股买进认寿
我跟你讲 你认寿你有交一整堂课
可是我现在已经忘记怎么做了
对啊 而且你买认寿
你摆那么久你也损失时间价值
对 我也不可能买认寿一直等逐全息
也不大好
对啊
那第三个呢
持有限股放空期货
什么期货
那我假如来放空大疆期货
也可以啦
但是你假如完全放空
那就失去它的意义了
对
你可以放空一点点可以
或者呢
今天交各位一招
生计医疗指数期货
对
这边赵华就要讲了
新鲜货
6月8号才刚挂牌上来
在期货市场刚挂牌
对
新的不得了
我今天有特别去玩一下
你特喜欢新鲜货
你真的很爱藏鲜
对啊 因为新的都要玩一下
要玩一下才可以教别人
好玩吗
蛮好玩的 造势不错
活动性又大
所以奇交所跟期货商
对政党是很用心
因为像大疆
它可能平常玩的人比较少
量比较没办法玩那么大
可是这个有造势的
就比较没问题
我想问
生计医疗指数期货
它有指数的成分
所以它裡面也是一螺框的股票
我就不用押估值
因为生技股
你知道定估值很可怕
没错
那大疆又在裡面权重是第一名
好股票权重第一名
所以它有什么特色
生技医疗指数企划
它是趋吉必凶
它可以找热门的生技类股的族群
没错
今年超热
高波动度
你最喜欢的
对 高杠杆
玩这个
这个完全根本就你的菜
玩这个很刺激
你只要花21000块
像我今天的波动
大概就5000块了
一口
21000块的波动到5000块
一口准备21000
波动有5000块
做错是很恐怖的
真的
做对赚起来也很快
在股票市场
我今天有个200块
我就高兴了
对啊
这个低交易成本
它的手续费
税金都很便宜
都很便宜
第一相关性呢
它跟大盘呢
比较没那么相关
所以这一个生机医疗指数期货
它是有个性的新货
对 有个性新货
自己走自己的路
没错
对
但是要了解它的个性
我才赚得到它的钱
对 没错
我要怎么了解它
要怎么了解它
对
好 这我们来看一下
我有兴趣耶
因为小哥你会跟我讲一些生机股嘛
我们对观众不能讲
私下可以讲
我没有一只敢买的
生机肋股很刺激啊
对啊
好
生技医疗指数期货
上日时间6月8号
6月8号就刚挂牌而已
英文代码叫做BTF
不是WTF
BTF
7月乘数50块
挑一点50块
一点50块
指数单4600点左右
就是6月8号上挂牌之后
每天涨跌幅也是算10%
涨停板
涨停板10%
跌幅也10%
交割方式也是现金结算
了解它的规则了
对 了解规则
我们来看一下
它里面有什么
它有前20大成分股
大江葡萄王成人
还有这个浩鼎 中玉 金华 东阳 国光生
保健部警生
一堆
这就是前20大成分股
太棒了
里面90%我都不敢买
我就一次买指数期货就好了
对 你可以买
这个成德波动很大
你买很怕
而且很多都是
不要怕 里面有葡萄王
对 因为你知道生技股
很多都是没获利
就涨翻了
又很飙的
变高价股
今年生技指数有涨
大盘还跌
对 所以我觉得今年生技
就是有点腰
说真的
对
所以我觉得齐教授
这时候推这个指数刚刚好
刚刚好
满足我们这种
又怕又想玩的人
又想玩的
生计指数它跟加权指数
其实它的关联性蛮低的
我们可以看得出来
刚刚有讲关联性低
是因为它很有个性
对我们看今年6月2号
生计指数跌1.6%
加权指数涨1.26%
就唱反调
唱反调
各走各的路
没错 5月28号
它跌加权指数涨1.15%
5月27号
生计指数跌1.8%
对
加权指数涨1.1%
是
像我这边画起来呢
就是这个生计跟加权呢
不同调
这边呢都是不同调
基本上根本没关系
因为就算同调涨幅也差很多
跌幅也差很多
对
所以呢你可以靠研究生计指数
拿来做这个生计期货
好
来获利
怎么做
我现在非常非常有兴趣
想要进入到实战的状态
对
来吧
我们来看一下
这个
币凶艾草大展神威
大展神威
假如你预期生计类股上涨
是
你就可以买台湾生计期货
但是小哥会涨还是会跌呢
这个你要判断一下
短线的筹码
好
木华哥在偷像
想说幸好我没问他
对
因为这边的话
它是上涨的话可以买吗
但是下跌当然也可以空
可是我们要怎么判断
涨跟跌等一下来考考两位好不好
我们要有一个基本的概念
其实我会看大江
因为大江算成分股算蛮重的
大江跌筹码不错
那就可以买入做多
而且是逢低买入
对逢低买入
好 那我们看这个
你看好就可以买一口
好 买进一口
假设当天从4600涨到4000
假设
涨了100点
100乘以50元
乘以一口
你就可以获利5000
5000块钱
这个杠杆很大
对
因为你才准备21000
21000可以瞬间
也不是瞬间就很快
赚到5000块
而且这个波动很常见
是
生技烈股波动常常都很大
21000你在台股涨停板
2000多块钱而已
对
可是你看这个
这个财涨2%
对
2%就5000块入袋了
所以杠杆很大
好
那预期生计类股下跌
你可以卖出生计期货
对
假设当天从4700
跌到4600
好 我卖出一口
那4700减4600
乘以50块一口
就5000块
做空也可以赚5000块
但方向就还蛮重要的
对 所以我们在这里要特别要讲
对
做期货的人怎么样会赔钱
看错方向会赔钱啊看错方向对凹单不停損不停損凹單對所以我們強烈建議
假設你4600買進
對
你就把停損單給掛出去了
4600買進
停損單也同時掛出去
停損單你可以掛
比如說你掛4570
OK
顏色停損點就對了
對
這個很重要
很多人只會掛停利單
不會掛停損單
你只要会挂停损单
那你就长期就小赔大赚
小赔大赚
这样会比较好一点
那孟华哥你觉得呢
因为生计的波动大
如果我今天去
它杠杆又那么大
我要怎么去盼到
它短期到底多跟空
杠很大其实不用太担心
我觉得保证金放多一点
保证金放多一点是不是
小哥刚刚讲说
一口两万多块保证金
那你就放十万块保证金
买一口
那这样相对你的风险就小了
你就不会说
这个动辄大坡动的话
就一言打电话来
叫你补保证金
对
所以我们保证金放多一点
我们因为基本上
我觉得其实
看对方向比较重要
保证金放多一点
也会心安点
那就口述一开始做的时候
你稍微不要做到这么多口
像小哥一次做100口这样子
我们就两口三口玩
对不对
木华哥背后可以插刀
没那么大
我们就有证据
木华哥也是做两三百口的人
那这里说方向要怎么样看
我觉得基本上
现在目前整个大盘
试在往上了
那试在往上的话
我觉得生技医疗
这一个类股是今年贵买指数
可以突破
而且是涨幅比大盘大
很重要的一个主轴
所以说在这样的一个情况之下
我觉得这一个类股
暂时还不会出现一个
很大的回档
所以只要有一个
稍微波段回档
我觉得应该还是一个
相对我们可以去做多的空间
就像刚刚小哥讲的
它里面成分股最高的是大疆
也许大疆在跌
如果筹码没有松动的时候
反而会是一个好的经常见
而且重点是大疆
其实现在目前的股价基期并不高
对 它今年没有大涨
大疆是经过前一波大跌下来
遇到利空整个大跌下来
尤其疫情很严重的时候
它的跌幅很大
所以说我觉得相对大疆
现在目前基期
比较没有那么高的情况之下
这个指数我觉得还有空间
所以我们可以不要那么空
可能以偏多来看待
相对我认为
我个人现在目前操作
这个指数会以比较偏多的心态来看
小哥已经下去实战了
对
小哥就是一个实战派
我来看要看对账单
马上要录这个就有对账单
我觉得很佩服你
为了录这个而下单
生平第一个
花钱比通告费领的还多的
还好有赚钱
还好没有把通告费赔掉
9.08分49秒
我就买了一口4635
这个生计指数上涨
往上走
那我到12点20分55秒
我觉得差不多了
反手又再空了10口
先买多
再买空
对 上面空
后面刚好跌下来
难怪这段时间都没有接我电话
对
就一路盯上去
再忙了 盘中很忙的
对
那这样子呢
各位看一下
这大概可以赚个50点
一口就可以赚多少
一口可以赚2500
就赚了50点
好
那这个
台湾生计期货
它就是个避凶爱潮
好
原私保证金2万1
2万1刚刚有讲
那点数我们算起来
4、6、4、6
乘以50点
相当于你有23万的合约
对
23万合约
这就是期货迷人
但也是
让大家会有点紧张的地方
你拿2万1
玩2、3万
对
那2、3万除以2万1
杠杠的11倍
好
重点是它很活泼
对
盘中常常这个1 2%很常见
对 可是因为如果买现股
像大疆它现在已经285
我就是如果我不融资
我就是28万5要放进去
其实我的现金压力又大了
对 大疆股价
这个一张就28万5
那假如准备21万
那你可以这个拿来避险的话
假设你有一张大疆
那你可以空一口来避险
你就可以规避
23万同类型的指数
所以基本上几乎是一口
就相当于大概一张大江
左右的那个波幅
对不对
它可以互相抵消掉
所以小哥你要让它全隐形吗
好
对
这个是真的差不多多空
我们才会全隐形它
对不对
我们来看一下
如果我们要全隐形怎么做
全隐形
全隐形就不用玩了
有的人说
小哥
那我买两张大疆空一口
大疆期货好吗
我说那大疆大涨跟大铁
都跟你没关系
你可能在做套利
那就干脆空手好了
干脆空手
好 假设
招数一
你可以买进大疆一张285
胡桃王一张195
那你持股市值相当于48万
48万
我买我只是想要零股息
像大江葡萄王
这个都还不错
我只要想要领股息
可是它跌的时候
我心又很痛怎么办
对 48万
两张就48万了
那只要两张都跌停
一天赔4万多
我都没有心情上班了
那怎么办呢
建议你就放空两口生计指数
空两口
因为空两口相当于大概46万
所以这个其实有点全隐形了
对不对
有一点隐形的概念了
好 这个假设
这边来试算一下
假设大江葡萄王当天涨10块
对 合起来涨10块
对 生计涨80点
好 那我原本呢
我赚1万的 对
因为它涨80点啊
所以呢我就赔钱了
因为我是放空嘛 没错
我是去避嫌 是
80点乘以50再乘以2
这是赔掉的钱
对 1.50块嘛
那你空两口
对 所以我原本赚1万块的
我后面只剩赚2000
这是现股赚1万
去扣掉你期货放空
亏了8000块钱
所以你只有赚到2000块钱
赚到2000
那假如大江葡萄王当天跌10块
那跌10块呢
可是我去放空这个生计指数
生计指数就跌了80点
那跌80点呢
我赔的1万
加上80点乘以50乘以2
赚了8000块
我赚了8000块
那我就怎么样
我就变我只剩赔2000
所以它没有到全影型
它让你小赚小赔
对 它很小赚小赔
减低你现在看不懂行情的风险
对 让你上班上得下去
然后要领股息还可以继续报
对
所以期货有个很好的功能
叫做避险
可是很多人玩期货
就每天跟他赌输赢
是啦 我觉得能拿期货避险
真的是比较法人心态
真的会避险
或是大户心态
其实我们都建议
小资族真的会比较喜欢冲
我们都建议要避险
我觉得要把这个心态建立起来
因为建立起来
我们就会跟大户
或是跟法人心情是一致的
这样子就比较不会毕业
对
可以继续在股市
期货市场继续下去
这个比较重要
跟雪人讲
最重要不是你赚多少
最重要的是你躺进棺材之前
你到底是赚还是赔
最重要是不要离场
因为其实像赵华一段时间
好 下跌的时候可能怕了
离场 一离场
其实你再上去这一段
会有很大一段空窗
因为我不敢再去把它追回来
所以基本上用这样的方式
可以保持你
不管在股市或者起步上
你没有离场
对 没有离场你就会知道动向
但是小哥讲了那么多
我的爱慕的眼光
还是一向的慕华哥
因为慕华哥现在看来是
证人君子派
刚才讲今年生计非常活泼
所以他有点腰
有点腰的话
就会有点害怕说
我判断错会不会受伤很惨重
所以听说莫华哥
这边有一档法宝
有一杯雄黄酒是
他清纯中带一点点叛逆
所以可以满足这种
你可能想要稍微赚一点波段
又不会太伤害的人
所以现在许仙出来了是不是
还是法师出来了
法师出来了
白蛇省害点
有看过这么胖的白蛇吗
人生公子
小哥是赚太多
这样太多
白蛇这样太多吃太好
许仙
好 许仙是什么呢
台湾永续指数期货
有没有听过
一听到永续指数
就是ESG
如果没有听过
永续指数期货的话
那一定听过台湾永续指数
有的
因为这个指数
已经出来很多年
而且也有一些公司
针对它发行ETF或者公司会标榜我是有得到这种永续经营的一个概念的郑交所旗下的子公司叫做台湾指数公司他们编制了很多很多指数
其中一个指数叫做
台湾永续指数
那这个指数不得了啊
怎么不得了个罚
里面全部都是大法师级的股票
对 但是会不会太乖
不会太乖
因为里面都会是
我们知道一定是基有股
而且非常有社会责任
没错
最近这十几年来
流行一个英文名词叫做ESG
对ESG
什么叫ESG呢
就是这个能进入到ESG这个概念
就代表这家公司
既有社会责任
又负责公司管理
而且经营绩效良好
否则进不了这个ESG的概念
所以现在全世界
根据这个概念
编列的ETF很多
像台湾就有
台湾有
所以这个概念的代表
是好公司的代表
而且你可以看到这些好公司
他们长期的绩效打败大盘
这我倒蛮意外的
因为我一直以为
好公司你就追踪大盘就好了
要像小哥介绍的生技股
才能真正打败大盘
我的想法是这样吗
生技股不是说不好
只是说生技股有时候
一到发布财报的时候
他们就变得比较不好了
现行了
生技股不是不好
平常很好
财报来的时候
大家要稍微闪一下
这个是部分生技股
但是名门正派生技股
还是很好
好 那我们来看一下
大法师到底有哪一些
里面有什么类鼓
我先给大家看一下
这个台湾永续指数的十大大法师
来 第一个台积电
台积电
护国神山
最近很强 真的很强
非常强 有没有
前一阵子其实它有点落后
最近马上就补回来了
前一阵子它比较落后
是因为外资大量到货
最近外资在认错
今年以来外资到了多少你知道吗
最惨的最惨的时候
台积电外资到了70万张
而且经济日报还把它变成头盘头条
说外资大卖台积电70万张
怕死人台积电
从那时候开始涨
但是现在外资回头了
外资发现我们
就是本土那支太夸张的厉害了
对
第二名鸿海最近也开始
也有
你看投信跟外资也开始在买了
对
第三名中华电信
7月2号要除息
除4块多
4.6多
也是非常好的高级
也是非常好的
而且基本上也没什么涨
也没什么跌
对不对
很平稳的一个
所谓的定存概念股
国泰金最近有没有涨
开始在动
金融股也是有存股行情
就是出圈席行情
南亚
台塑四宝
最近也不错
曾经一度跌得很惨
但是最近开始也在涨
富邦金也一样跟国泰金在动
联邦克不要讲了
上500块了
标股
对好可惜
他本来跟台电类似的价格
现在要领先了
然后中信金统一中钢
你发现最近外资也开始在买中钢
这个真的是
妙的
有没有很妙
我觉得他们急了
所以这十大的成分股
你知道占了这个指数的权重
已经多少了吗
光这十档
拿把它记下来
占这个指数已经高达57%了
所以这十档
几乎可以代表这个指数了
对
然后刚刚小哥不是有讲说
大疆吗
跟生计期货吗
其实这个更好做
更好做为什么
因为这一档
就占这个指数30%
我懂你的意思了
你今天节目一开始有提醒我们
现在要看台积电
对
所以等于说这档指数
它跟台积电息息相关
对 所以如果你看好台积电
端午节后会一路上的话
对
那请问更大的杠杆
更好操作
不是这个期货吗
我有个疑问
那我就买大盘就好了
问题是大盘
你不管买0050 0056
或是你买这个台子期
你付出的成本要更多
我们这个成本比较低
是
我们付出的保证金相对规模
期货合约规格小
我们访问金就低
因为我现在买一张台积电
要30万以上
我也买不下手
所以稍微介绍一下
这个所谓的避险生气
好 我们大家不要以为是GEO公司
它就不会涨 不会跌
不是
它有一定的波动的
什么时候上市
6月8号
也是6月8号新货驾到
我们要尬一下
尬一下
两个都6月8号
然后英文代码14F
我们不要念14F
这样怂掉了
E-for-F
For是什麼
Forever
永續有沒有
永續Forever
是不是 取得很好有沒有
就是你幫他取的吧
當然啊
E是什麼
ESG嘛
ESG forever
好記嘛
跟他那個BTF一樣
來 然後契約乘數
我們是乘100
一口一點100
他比較高貴
剛才我們哥哥是50
對不對 為什麼他50
我們100
我們是法師啊
沒有啦 因為我們
我們的這個重量級夠重
比較穩定
它相對它波動大
所以我們保護一下投資人
OK 好 我們是100
而且這一檔指數的話
它其實跟我們大盤比起來
它也是略活潑對不對
當然啊
我們不會介紹大家
死板板的商品
對 因為如果它跟大盤一樣
說實話我跟大盤做就好
或是0050做就好了
那我們就來看波動度對不對
對
波動度各位可以看到
我们这个台湾永续指数的波动
因为我们这期货是根据这个指数
所以我们就要看它的一个目标地
它的benchmark
你看它的波动度
今年是30.86
那我们如果看2015年的6月22号
到今年的4月30号
它的平均波动是15.96
可是我们看到今年有没有很大波动
有啊
今年有非常大波动
比过去放大几乎一倍
所以今年这个指数的一个活泼性就更高了
那你相对加全值
它相对比加全子的一个波动
今年稍微小一点
但是它长期而言
你有没有看到
它的波动是比加全子大的
大一些的
对不对
然后你来看到相关系数
0.995
0.99
0.969
其实相关系数蛮高的
它等于曲线线型跟大盘一模一样
对我们来看一下曲线线型
赵华讲到这一点
我们就准备了一个资料
给大家看一下
这个两个曲线图
一个是大盘
一个是台湾永续子
有沒有亦步亦趨
沒錯 他們看起來像
就是他們的線型漲一樣
可是波動度有一點差別
好 那你可以就搭配什麼
搭配0050的ETF
來做套利啊
來做避險啊
還有新玩法對不對
對啊 那你可以搭配台積電
來做套利避險
好 我舉個例子好了
假如像小哥這麼大戶對不對
對 台積電有一千張
唉唷 是
先空好指數
他有一千張
再往下砸嗎
結果呢 他真的有
他突然發現有一個事情
不太對勁
是
美国突然股市出现崩盘
对
半导体类股一面倒
对 但台积电是小哥的心肝宝贝
他又不想卖
那怎么办呢
他是不是可以去空
100口的台湾永续指数期货
来做避险
对 空个十分之一
因为台积电还是好嘛
所以他是短期避险
没错
所以他就可以去这样子做
台积电的现货的避险
好 那假设说像我
一张台积电都买不起了
怎么办呢
但是我看好台积电怎么办呢
那我就去买进台湾
永续指数期货
去代替台积电
这样子就一个
很好的避险神器
跟一个所谓的爱草神器
所以非常谢谢两位
今天来跟大家介绍了
两档6月8号新上市的
一个新的期货指数
一个是台湾永续的期货指数
另外一个是台湾的
生计医疗的指数期货
所以今天大家有没有听懂
就是说如果今天端午节
有变盘的疑虑
不过两位答案都告诉你
短期间内好不好
不要太空
我们不要跟市场对坐
然后小哥讲了一个很棒的方法
如果你对生机疗有兴趣
其实你就去买这个
生机疗指数期货就好了
因为它里面有20几档的成分股
而且它里面
你可以看它的指标股就是大疆
大疆的涨别
其实关乎到这个指数期货的一个动态
那穆华哥教你
如果你真的很害怕
生机指数有一点点腰
对不对
那你就去买永续
台灣永續指數期貨
因為它是台灣一些好公司的集合
尤其裡面權重最大是台積電
你看好台積電
就來做這檔指數期貨就好了
所以今天兩檔新貨上市
6月8號都已經上市了
而且小哥已經幫你試完了
小哥說造勢非常成功非常好
所以不要錯過
試試看好不好
試試你的手氣
來試試看
然後還有趙華要提醒大家一點
避險是大戶跟法人會做的
千萬不要覺得自己是散戶
避險就不重要
當你學會了
你就往大户的路上邁进了
那今天理财单秀就到这边了
我们下次再见
拜拜